jean lui vous continuez de karaté ou pas
non je fais télé maintenant télé télé
sur tara this way
cette ceinture noire ceinture non vous
étiez ceinture noire regardez ce que
vous avez fait la dernière fois
regarde toi j'en ai fait ça
oui jean luc lemoine la dernière
et ce alors il s'était attaqué à
christophe carrière moi c'est le game
one ces jeunes imaginent que c'est pas
possible
les sorties du plateau jean ping an peut
pas changer mais comme exercice tu sais
parce que en fait je pense que cet homme
thème intrinsèquement est vraiment
dément j'ai lu que la dernière fois dont
vous avez fait ça avec donc christophe
carrière et moi aujourd'hui on a un
adversaire à notre mesure à votre taille
le roi des arts martiaux le numéro un
l'homme le plus nerveux de france non ça
n'est pas jean luc mélenchon non c'est
l'autre tout de suite le jeu et je
frappe
jean luc reichmann contre chuck norris
est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
succinct conneries là vous êtes toujours
sur france 4 touche pas à mon poste à ma
droite c'est de tout casser de lombrics
cassés de la brique contre le champion
du monde demandant si le trou de souris
[Applaudissements]
la famille va bien
abba mamma mia vas-y la pac mois a pas
que moi aussi je rajouterais que moi
rabobank des frères attendait parce qu'à
la réalisation juste toi je fais une
petite parenthèse
regardez comme il a mis sa ceinture
c'est normal ans et tu mets tout à
lambert petit scarabée race et on me met
deux mois en brie bâtissons le crash
mais non mais tous devant mais tous
devant mais tous les habitants n'ont
rien jeter au feu et m'a remis le boul
chaque toit casser ça moi que c'est ça
le grand jeu de moi car c'est ça alors
attention donc choc la casse indique ses
choix une brique ce partage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
tu vas dire couper du bois est ralentie
et lancel ralentir ce qui m'a
impressionné
haidar et comment il a fait ça
oh là là dessus du tapis at war mais toi
maintenant de briques de bruce et y est
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
oui normalement c'est non non pas pressé
je n'ai pas toi temps je voudrais je ne
voudrais pas trop pressée suis en amour
divin que je garde tout en lui car est
donc assez pour toi cassé toi arrête toi
cassé
[Applaudissements]
alors je voulais juste te dire un truc
ralentit encore jean-luc d'impression il
ya cassé de briques 10 et un last mon
cas j'aurais juste un truc je vais te
dire ce mec là il est payé tu sais
combien a coûté pour le terminer
donc je veux bien qu'ils cassent un truc
non
papa des baguettes en pièces de théâtre
merci vanished les gaffes attention
toutefois ce n'est pas ce que c'est il
faut qu'il se concentre les semaines je
suis dégoûté maintenant parce que là il
peut se faire mal paraître chirac
[Musique]
jean luc est ce que tu penses que tu
peux casser trois planches ce qu'il ya
d'important en fait c'est juste pour
expliquer aux téléspectateurs
c'est qu'ici c'est très très dur et là
ça fait un peu la donne au oui c'est
vrai et de trucs c'est arrivé a bien
contracté celui ci et qui permet à près
de bien prendre sur les sur les saisies
records ça
[Applaudissements]
à
tu attends juste essayer ça une belle
saison normalement il devrait pouvoir
sauf problème mesdames et messieurs
cyril hanouna dans tout dans touche pas
à ma planche est ma vie je suis avec toi
ta mère te regarde attends-moi consentir
à 10 juste leur milieu en juste omis ne
te fais pas mal hein vas-y vas-y mon
père est né là-bas tarn et rennais va
pas bien dans le milieu mais rien de
démissionner
attention
il fait non
les applaudissements fusent
c
dans un gâteau que je suis assez
satisfait vendredi avec de travail
discutent à voix c'est toi je suis
énervé je suis énervé très fort quand
même
j'ai du mal à croire que c'est moi